Chechenia es una isla de integrismo islámico
en mitad de la Rusia de Vladimir Putin.
Tal cual como lo oís. En ese país que presume
de ser la reserva espiritual de Occidente,
el último baluarte de la cristiandad… es
donde se encuentra la República de Chechenia,
un lugar donde ni siquiera podemos comprar
vodka porque nadie se atreve a venderlo.
Y ya sé lo que me vais a decir… “Fonseca…
acabas de decir la “REPÚBLICA de CHECHENIA…
¿No habías dicho que esa una región dentro
de Rusia?” Lo cierto es que la Federación
Rusa es el país más grande del mundo en
cuanto a territorio. Y eso significa que si
distribución territorial es un auténtico
rompecabezas. La mayor parte del país está
dividido en los llamados OBLAST, que serían
algo parecido a los estados de Estados Unidos.
Tienen su propio gobernador y su propio parlamento
pero siempre están supeditados al la Constitución
y el Gobierno de Moscú. Sin embargo, hay
otras partes del país que prácticamente
funcionan como países independientes. Tienen
su propia constitución, su propio lenguaje
y hasta su propia religión
oficial. Una de estas repúblicas, por ejemplo,
es la de Crimea, que no está reconocida ni
por Estados Unidos ni por la Unión Europea
pero que, de facto, está controlada por Rusia.
Veréis, “en teoría”, la ley rusa garantiza
muchísima autonomía a estas repúblicas.
Pero digo “en teoría”
porque ya sabéis que a Vladimir Putin le
gusta tener todo el país bajo control. De
hecho, prácticamente todos los presidentes
de estas repúblicas rusas pertenecen al partido
político de Putin: Rusia Unida. Y cuando
alguno de estos gobiernos se desvía ligeramente
de la línea del Kremlin, pasan cosas como
esta.
“Tatarstan, la última región en perder
su estatus especial bajo Putin”
Sin embargo, hay una república con la que
Putin no se atreve. Sí, sí, habéis oído
bien. Vladimir Putin, el Chuck Norris de la
política, también tiene que agachar la cabeza
de vez en cuando. Especialmente cuando hablamos
de CHECHENIA.
“Es difícil saber quién manda a quién.
Los observadores rusos en la región se quejan
de que la ley rusa y la autoridad terminan
en la frontera con Chechenia”
Por ejemplo, en Chechenia el uso del hijab
se promueve desde el propio gobierno. La poligamia
y los matrimonios con menores de edad están
tolerados. Y ningún restaurante se atreve
a abrir durante el día en la época del Ramadán.
Sin embargo, cualquiera de estas cosas palidece
ante lo que la prensa ha revelado en abril
de este año 2017.
“Chechenia abre los primeros campos de concentración
para homosexuales”
Vale, es cierto que Putin no es tampoco el
campeón de los derechos LGTB, precisamente.
Pero abrir campos de concentración son palabras
mayores. Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué
Putin no se atreve a imponer orden en Chechenia?
¿Qué tiene el presidente Checheno, RAMZAN
KADYROV, para que Putin le permita campar
a sus anchas? Hoy vamos a responder a esta
pregunta, pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
LA SICILIA DEL CÁUCASO
Durante siglos, Chechenia estaba gobernado
por grandes clanes que controlaban un territorio.
Cada uno de estos clanes, conocidos con el
nombre de TUKKHUM, estaba integrado por cientos
de familias, lo que en checheno se llama los
TEIP. Para que nos entendamos, era algo parecido
al sistema de la mafia siciliana: todo quedaba
entre familias. Y, de la misma forma que la
mafia siciliana es un sistema político que
ha resistido a toda clase de invasiones, este
sistema de TUKKHUM chechenos, ha sobrevivido
tanto a los zares como a la Unión Soviética.
“Debemos ser soviéticos en público y musulmanes
en privado”
(Proverbio Checheno)
En otras palabras, que durante la época soviética,
existían dos sistemas políticos paralelos.
Por un lado, el comunismo oficial e impuesto
por Moscú, y por el otro, esta jerarquía
de clanes y familias. Por eso, cuando en el
año 1991, la Unión Soviética desaparece,
los Chechenos aprovechan este momento de debilidad
y declaran la REPÚBLICA CHECHENA DE ICHKERIA.
El nombre os sonará porque salía en uno
de los juegos de la saga Call of Duty.
El por entonces flamante presidente democrático
de la nueva Federación Rusa, BORIS YELTSIN,
respondió con la fuerza.
“Yeltsin declara el estado de emergencia
y el toque de queda en la región de Chechenia”
Sin embargo, este estado de emergencia fracasó
por completo. El ejército ruso fue incapaz
de frenar a los rebeldes Chechenos y tuvo
que marcharse con el rabo entre las piernas
¡Pero no sólo eso! Al marcharse, los separatistas
terminaron quedándose con buena parte del
armamento de los soldados que había venido
desde Moscú. Así que, durante 3 largos años,
el Kremlin tuvo que hacer la vista gorda con
Chechenia. Sin embargo, las cosas cambiaron
en 1994.
“Puedes construir un trono con bayonetas…
pero es difícil sentarse en él” –Boris
Yeltsin
¿Recordáis que os dije que el sistema político
de Chechenia se basaba en distintos clanes,
esos llamados TUKKHUM, que dominaban las distintas
partes de la república? Pues… lo cierto
es que no se llevaban demasiado bien entre
ellos. Y por eso estalló una guerra civil
en esta república. Una guerra civil que,
desde el Kremlin, se veía como una oportunidad
perfecta para recuperar el control. Pero,
un año más tarde y después de que el ejército
ruso perdiera casi 6000 soldados, al bueno
de Boris YELTSIN no le queda otro remedio
que firmar un acuerdo de paz con el Gobierno
de Chechenia. Un gobierno separatista y absolutamente
débil. Mientras tanto, muchos terroristas
islámicos de Arabia Saudita o Afganistán
estaban volando a GROZNI, la capital chechena,
para reclutar nuevos miembros. A fin de cuentas,
un estado fallido, tribal y donde el Islam
es la religión mayoritaria, es el caldo de
cultivo para un terrorista islámico. En otras
palabras, que era cuestión de tiempo que
estallara otra guerra en la zona. Y eso ocurrió
en el año 1999, cuando un grupo de rebeldes
islamistas chechenos invade la república
de al lado; la República de Dagestán.
Es decir, que no contentos con dar problemas
en su propio territorio, los chechenos estaban
atacando otras partes de Rusia. Como os podéis
imaginar, el Kremlin tenía que enviar a sus
tropas de nuevo. Pero esta vez era distinto.
Sí, el presidente seguía siendo Boris Yeltsin
pero el Primer Ministro era… el único,
el inigualable, el mejor amigo de VisualPolitik…
¡Vladimir PUTIN!
En seguida, Putin se puso en contacto con
uno de estos líderes separatistas Chechenos,
el señor AKHMAD KADYROV. Así que le dijo
“Kadyrov, jomío, ve aca pacá… mira,
yo te voy a cubrir de oro, te voy a dar todas
armas y el poder que necesites, puedes hacer
lo que quieras en Chechenia pero con una condición;
no quiero ni guerras ni terrorismo”. Y como
decimos en VisualPolitik… dicho y hecho.
La guerra terminó. Y Kadyrov utilizó todas
esas ayudas que le llegaban desde el Kremlin
para reprimir a todos los demás señores
de la guerra que poblaban su república.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Funcionó? La respuesta
es sí y no. Por supuesto que las guerras
terminaron. Pero muchos de estos patriarcas
chechenos organizaron atentados terroristas
en otras zonas de Rusia, incluida Moscú.
En el caso de Moscú, un grupo de terroristas
secuestraron a más de 300 civiles en un teatro.
De esos 300 rehenes, 170 murieron. En otras
palabras, que el plan tenía sus fisuras.
Y la autoridad de Kadyrov era, cuanto menos,
discutible. Tanto es así que unos años más
tarde, murió en otro atentado terrorista
en Grozny… Y aquí es cuando entró en escena
el personaje crucial de esta historia.
LA ESTRELLA DE INSTAGRAM
RAMZAN KADYROV sucedió a su padre en el poder.
Y aprendió una valiosa lección; si quieres
crear una dictadura, hazlo a lo grande. Hablamos
de un lugar lleno de señores de la guerra
luchando entre ellos, donde organizaciones
como Al Qaeda o el DAESH se dedican a reclutar
a nuevos miembros que pueden desafiar tu poder.
En otras palabras, que KADYROV Junior no estaba
dispuesto a dejar que esas cosas raras de
los demócratas como los Derechos Humanos
le quitaran el sueño. Además, contaba con
el apoyo, el dinero y las armas de Putin ¿Qué
más se puede pedir?
“Le debo la vida a Putin. Si olvidara esto,
no sería un hombre. Cuando pasé por un momento
terrible en mi vida, me ayudó. Para mí,
es el hombre más santo”—Ramzan Kadyrov.
Lo cierto es que, desde que Kadyrov hijo llegó
al poder, los atentados de terroristas chechenos
en suelo ruso han desaparecido ¡No sólo
eso! Las células de Al Qaeda y el DAESH están
cayendo, una tras otro. La policía de Kadyrov
les persigue, les expulsa del país junto
con sus familias o, simplemente, les quema
la casa. Por si todo esto fuera poco, los
soldados de Kadyrov se ofrecieron voluntarios
para las misiones más peligrosas de Ucrania.
Es más, para mostrar su amistad y su amor
eterno hacia Putin, Raznam Kadyrov
organizó un enorme desfile militar en el
Estadio de fútbol de Grozny. Miles de militares
clamaban al Presidente Checheno, dispuestos
a morir por él.
“Si Putin me dice que le mande mi ejército…
¡Estoy listo!”—Raznam Kadyrov
Sin embargo… las cosas no son tan dulces
como parecen. En este desfile militar, Kadyrov
estaba lanzando dos mensajes: 1. Putin es
mi amigo y 2. Si algún día Putin deja de
ser mi amigo, aquí tengo un ejército que
me es leal dispuesto a morir por mí. Sí,
amigos de VisualPolitik, si en algún momento,
Vladimir Putin quisiera enfrentarse a su viejo
amigo checheno… lo tendría bastante complicado.
Y las muestras de poder no son pocas. De hecho,
todos los enemigos políticos de Kadyrov han
sido asesinados, independientemente de dónde
estuvieran. Desde periodistas residentes en
Moscú hasta opositores políticos exiliados
en San Petesburgo… ¿Qué significa todo
esto? Pues que el gobierno de GROZNI tiene
a su propia KGB infiltrada por todo el país.
Y que no tiene ningún inconveniente en utilizarlos
en cuanto alguien, sea checheno o no, se levante
contra él.
En otras palabras, que Putin creó a Raznam
Kadyrov y ahora es lo suficientemente poderoso
como para mirarle frente a frente. Eso explica
que, a diferencia de los presidentes de cualquier
otra república rusa, Kadyrov se atreva a
opinar públicamente sobre asuntos de política
internacional. O que el Kremlin haga la vista
gorda cuando, desde Grozny deciden crear campos
de concentración de homosexuales.
“Rusia apoya al Gobierno de Chechenia cuando
niega que haya matado y torturado a homosexuales”
Mientras tanto, Chechenia es cada vez más
rico gracias a Rusia. De hecho, el 90% de
su riqueza viene, directamente, del dinero
que le envía el Kremlin. Y Kadyrov ha creado
una república donde el culto al líder es
algo así como la segunda religión, sólo
por detrás del Islam. Su cuenta de instagram
tiene casi 3 millones de seguidores. Desde
ahí podéis ver el estilo de vida de uno
de los dictadores más salvajes del mundo,
y a la vez, el único al que Putin tiene miedo.
Y ahora la pregunta es… ¿Llegaremos a ver
un enfrentamiento entre Vladimir Putin y Raznam
Kadyrov? ¿Debería el Kremlin tratar de evitar
las violaciones de Derechos Humanos en Chechenia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto.